PROFESSOR: So there's a
lot of images in the class,
partly because we're
studying these materials
and you can see just with the
ones sitting in front of me,
they have this porous,
cellular structure.
So I show lots of
images of materials.
We also look at how the
images deform under load.
And I think, perhaps,
that's something that
might be a little unexpected.
So for instance, we have a
stage in the electron microscope
where we can actually deform
things in the microscope.
And the stage is set up that
it has a load cell on it.
And we could also measure how
much it deforms, the materials.
So we can actually watch the
materials as they're deforming.
So even though the cells
may be 100 micron size,
you can watch how they
deform and how they fail,
and you're going to learn
a lot about the mechanics
from these sorts
of observations.
So we have both video of
these deformations and also
still photography at different
time points that we show.
Another interesting little video
clip that I show in the class
is we look at the interactions
between biological cells
and tissue
engineering scaffolds.
So for example,
people who've looked
at trying to heal, say,
burns in skin where there's
a large area of
skin missing, one
of the ways that
you can do that is
by using a collagen-based
tissue engineering scaffold.
And when you have
a burn in your skin
and it just heals the normal way
and you get all the scar tissue
forming, that scar
tissue is thought
to form in conjunction
with a process of what's
called wound contraction.
So cells will actually
migrate into the wound bed
and actually mechanically
pull the edges of the wound
together, and that partly closes
the wound and then scar forms
as well.
And those two
processes are thought
to be related to each other.
So I've done a collaboration
with Professor Ioannis Yannas
here at MIT who developed
one of these scaffolds
for burn patients.
And he and I have been
interested in this wound
contraction problem.
And it turns out if you just
put fibroblast skin cells
into a dish of culture medium
with one of these tissue
engineering scaffolds, they
will contract the scaffold.
And you can use an
optical microscope
to actually watch
the cells do this.
So you can focus on
an individual cell
and you can see the
cell elongating.
You can see the scaffold
itself contracting.
And you can see
this whole process.
So this is one of the
little video clips
that we show in class.
And the students always
find that fascinating.